[Music]
Don uses sports agent and represents a
variety of clients he represents Tom
Brady Jimmy Garoppolo Julian Edelman
Sean Payton let's see who else is on his
Larry Allen so he's got quite a few
clients there and I saw what what Don
was doing he wants to start a league and
instead of going to college that you can
come right out of high school but he
didn't want to take the leftovers who
didn't make it to college he wanted to
see if you could get some of the cream
of the crop here instead of going to
college you can go into this
Developmental League I guess you know so
I had questions if who's gonna televise
it is it something that Amazon or
Netflix or Yahoo or somebody might get
involved in this where are you gonna
play the money that you need so we bring
in Donny the sports agent kind enough to
join us Don good morning explain the new
league to our audience sure thanks for
having me on dan and I apologize if I
sound a little nasal e-ville under the
weather this morning but when Todd Fritz
calls you got a rally you got a play
hurt sometimes Dan every day is a Super
Bowl around here done there you go
there you go so Pacific Pro Football
pack Pro for short will be a 14
Professional Football League initially
based in Southern California with play
to begin in July 2018 player rosters
projected at 50 players each with an
average salary and benefits package of
$50,000 per player and the player
population we're looking at our players
that are four years or less removed from
their high school graduation date and
the coaching staffs that we project they
will have former NFL and college coaches
and it will be a development ground for
officials and coaches and executives as
well and there's really two primary
objectives Dan well I would say three
the first one would be that we want to
develop
these players in the professional style
of football which is very different than
the amateur style anybody that's watched
the two can tell that there's an
immediate difference there and the gulf
between the two is growing wider the
second thing we want to do is make the
game safer dan and you know these
players as they're developing we feel
that there are modifications to the game
that can be made that will make the game
safer for the players and pack Pro will
always have the health safety and
welfare of the players at the forefront
the final thing we want to do is really
try to help these players try to explore
what their life passions are outside of
football so that they can at least make
some steps toward establishing a path
for their life when football is over but
as a fan though that where would I be
able in a nutshell where would I be able
to watch these games how importantly
question we've already had some
preliminary discussions with potential
content distributors and the interesting
thing in our research dan going through
this as we're studying this you know we
live now in a technology world there
where there are more content
distribution options than ever you've
even got the major broadcast networks
you know scrambling to try to figure out
what the new landscape is going to look
like and so there are more of those
options and the next generation behind
us is more open-minded as to how they
consume their entertainment but when you
look at that the other side of the coin
in terms of if you want live football
game programming actually there's not
much inventory out there because the
major properties already are locked up
under long-term contracts so we feel
that we can provide more inventory
create more jobs and service some of the
growing number of content distributors
are you going to be recruiting high
school kids are they going to be in high
school when you're recruiting them
there's great question the player pools
as we see it will be there potentially
could be kids directly from high school
there may be players who are playing at
a very high level and Community College
and currently being recruited by major
Division one schools there may be
current players on the visual and
rosters who are not playing for one
reason or another and there also may be
players who have played very well as
freshmen or sophomores in college and
who might be interested in playing
impact Pro for one year and starting
their professional development a year
early as well as marketing themselves
and making a salary and then the final
player pool that we looked at is there's
a lot of interest in actually from
international players the American game
is becoming more and more popular in
places like Germany and Australia and in
fact the NFL just drafted their first
player from Germany this past season
directly from Germany so those would be
the player pools could you see this
actually pushing the n-c-double-a
towards maybe paying players you know
like minimum yeah I don't really know
Dan I mean I've read a lot of commentary
over the last 24 hours about that but I
really don't have any idea what they're
thinking might be I'm just kind of
focused on trying to build a new model
and when we looked at the football
landscape we felt that football's been a
sport that actually hasn't seen much
innovation lately and we've seen
innovation in all other areas of
American society I think the NBA just
recently announced for six weeks ago
that they're going to be opening
basketball academies all around the
world
and so we just felt that it was the
right time for innovation in football
and we hope to expand the industry how
would you make money off of this all
leagues tend to look at traditional
revenue model stands you know such as
gate concession media rights licensing
merchandising and so we've looked at all
those traditional streams as well as
possibly some more innovative streams
he's done Yee NFL agent if Tom Brady
calls right now did you have to hang up
yes although I would say that I would be
leaving the red carpet of the sports
world to take that call okay
now and he might say you know what stay
on with that okay if if Garoppolo calls
do you guys you get off the phone yes
and when you become a pain client I
would get off the phone for you - you
would yes okay I was curious if the
Commissioner congratulated Tom Brady for
being the winningest quarterback of all
time did he get a phone call from the
Commissioner this year I'm not sure
about that I don't really know if he did
or didn't you know during the season you
know tom is all business nobody and he
just set the record he surpassed Peyton
Manning he's won more games than any
other quarterback in history and not
worthy of a phone call well you know I
that's out of my jurisdiction
but you know we were very happy for him
obviously
that you know he's kind of focused on
the next one how bad do you want to see
Brady up there on the podium with the
Commissioner getting that Lombardi
Trophy well you you always want to see
any of your cleaner you are dying to see
that we all are yeah well there you go
it would be good luck with this we'll
keep an eye on it and thanks for joining
us Don good to talk to you again thanks
for inviting me damn right that's Don
you sports agent the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
you